all right I am on with Joe from Egypt
can I call you Joe or should I call you
the last Pharaoh yeah Joe's fine just
fine Joe a vibe I thought it would be
like a bit awkward so yeah alright so
for people that don't know you you're
the only person we selected out of the
20 people that I actually do know of
because I follow you on Twitter and you
are a youtuber by the name of the last
Pharaoh and you do really some great
videos talking about atheism and
secularism and being an ex-muslim and
the regressive left all of this stuff
but before we get into that tell me
you're 31 in Egypt how is life in Egypt
these days well it's kind of okay I mean
by a look when people ask me that
question I always like to think you like
to give myself some hope to say at least
I'm not living in Afghanistan or Saudi
Arabia so you're not be honest yeah just
be able to you know to function and
actually like on a day-to-day basis I
really don't feel like that much of you
know just like for other people other
people are getting it like bad but for
me yet maybe because I just have like
thick skin or something I don't know I'm
not really feeling that affected so yeah
so we don't have to go too much into the
politics cuz I want to really focus on
what you're doing but you know it was
only what three four years ago that the
Arab Spring happened and you guys lived
under Mubarak who was basically a
military dictator for 30-something years
you then you had the Muslim Brotherhood
by democratic elections for a year then
they get overthrown by the military
again and that's where you're at now
yeah
so two people there what how do they
feel just about the whole system is
there a feeling that democracy is ever
gonna come back do they want democracy
to come back cuz it didn't really work
for that year like what's the feeling
there well you have to like
differentiate between like two like
classes of people so you have like that
majority of Egyptians like the normal
everyday like kind of people do I would
say they're like I don't know they're
not happy right now as they should but
they're like kind of
okay with it like what would look at the
current like government they were not
happy during the Muslim Brotherhood even
more even less happy than they were
under Mubarak so that that was like that
was not gonna work at all that the whole
thing yeah so but the political question
Egypt which are happy to think that like
90% of them are idiots but yeah they're
not happy with anything which i think is
like did they have like this like kind
of like regressive is JW kind of a thing
happening like all the time and they're
not focusing on what's important so they
just make big deals about nothing
while not talking about really people
going to jail for just saying like
normal like just stupid [ __ ] yeah I say
people are going to jail for making
jokes about feeling like balloon condoms
with air and handing them out so they
just send them to prison
some people just went to prison because
they do like sketch comedy on YouTube or
something they sent him to prison
so I think the most important thing that
that needs to change in Egypt not the
regime not the economy and they're just
doing what they can I mean the
government they have they have an
interest to just do as bit as best as
they can
what I really think is important is the
whole free speech and like the blasphemy
law that the modesty was these kind of
laws need to go because the Constitution
actually doesn't allow yeah some people
should just focus on that raising the
money getting those like laws in front
of the Parliament or in front even the
Constitutional Court because the the
Egyptian Constitution if you read it and
forget it from Egypt you really wouldn't
know that's from Egypt because it's like
99.9% secular like really freedom of
speech like has its own article that's
like totally guaranteed no restrictions
no limitations under any circumstances
so the fact that we have laws punishing
people because the insulted this guy or
the president or like some I don't know
anyone it's unconstitutional it's like
100 percent unconstitutional yes so with
all that in mind I mean where do you get
the balls to do what you do you're
showing me your face right now I asked
you before we started recording if it
was okay if we wanted to do something
different or whatever
we're a mask or whatever but I mean
you'd put your videos out there with
your voice your you're incredibly brave
and clear and honest I mean just okay
just I don't see that way actually
okay yeah I don't see it like that I
just see it like I said that before to a
lot of people I'm not doing the videos
and honestly to hide I just like my you
know my privacy can I don't like putting
my face on camera all the time yeah but
even if I was living in America or
something I would still do the videos
around me people seem to miss that point
I said that all the time I'm not hiding
I just don't like putting my face on
camera I just don't like don't like see
myself on camera so that's it I'm not
and and to me it's like I don't know
it's like I'm tired I'm like 31 but I
feel like I'm 60 I'm tired I'm not gonna
hide I'm not gonna censor myself anymore
just like people seem to forget that on
a daily basis I have to pretend to be
someone else like everyone around me
yeah even when I'm getting a haircut
I have to like agree with the guys
cutting my hair that the weather we have
like a particularly hot summer these
days that the weather is like a lot of
thing and and you know we have to be
thankful because some people got it
worse so I have to agree with that like
every single minute of every single day
so I'm not gonna censor myself online
that's like that so wait you have to you
have to thank all of that it's really
hot but not hotter than really hot yeah
yeah so basically yeah every Muslim
country is you have to be thankful
because you're not like the worst thing
so as long as like there's one guy
that's worse than you you have to be
thankful Oh a guy and that guy should
like have a problem with God seriously
they can always can always get work so I
get it all right so I want to talk a
little bit about your personal stuff so
you are an atheist and you consider
yourself an ex-muslim correct yeah so so
you put these videos out there and you
have you have a real fan base it's
awesome what about in your own personal
life they're like are you are you out to
your friends and family like how much
can you talk about that stuff well look
like friends and family like the
I'm not like religious that's like what
they know and they know that I'm kind of
like you know I just don't care about
any of that stuff they know that but
they don't know that I'm like a hundred
percent it is actually the idea wouldn't
even enter their minds even if I told
them they would be like you know they're
not my pudding like because the options
not on the table hearing like Egypt or
in the Muslim countries it's not an
option to be an atheist yeah no one knew
that no one told me that so if someone
would have told me that when I was like
six years old because I always wasn't
like compliant with religion so if
someone would have told me that like
when I was young the idea matter of like
mattered like me that that's which a
long time ago but the idea was anything
there so when did you make that switch
when did you wake up I think it was like
about three years ago I had some like
you know like I had like a major event
happened in my life so I had to stop
because I was just going and I wasn't
like really paying attention but I never
really was a Muslim if you really like
considered it like what how I was living
I never really was didn't even stop to
think you know what maybe this is all
[ __ ] I never stopped to say that to
myself
but when my life just stopped me by
forcefully stopped I I had some time to
like reflect and think and just reach a
conclusion that was just like right
there but I never really even considered
it yeah and did you jump on YouTube
right after that because the stuff that
you do there is really great we'll put a
link below so everyone can find it yes
so is it though is a great thing you
know yeah but III think you're brave for
having me actually I'm brave I think
your average no no because like my
videos are not really like advertiser
friendly or something they don't really
but I don't follow like come on like
yeah so so ya know what actually made me
jump from unity was I know it's like a
cliche at this point but actually was
the same Harris Ben Affleck thing I mean
it was like that was my awakening - so
we're across the world yeah it was like
no no no no no someone
like someone needs to have this guy's
back because he's like he's like taking
all the heat he's saying something
that's so obvious and it's like
ridiculous for people and actually not
lunch is the interview the next day on
CNN and all that that was like a [ __ ]
show it was like can I say that you
could say it go crazy you could say more
than that can [ __ ] you so yeah yeah I
had to like say something I actually
uploaded two videos and deleted them but
then I uploaded the third one because I
wasn't really sure about the other thing
I it was like okay if I get like a
hundred views on that okay I'll do a
second one and it just yeah keep going
from there
think how awesome that is really I mean
we live something like I don't know
eight thousand miles away from each
other and that moment that same night I
mean that was my awakening I had had a
little a little crack in in my awakening
before that and and but we had that
together that that is so cool so I'm
thrilled to be talking to you but I'll
go ahead yeah yeah you're a good host -
all right so you know we only have that
we all live like another minute but I'll
do something else with you in the future
but just talk to me a little bit about
the regressives because you you hate
them as much as I do this is this
regressive ideology so how does it
affect you as a free thinker and a
secularist and an atheist in Egypt how
does their ideology harm you your
ability to live the way you want well
they're basically shutting down any
conversation that could lead to anything
because when you're talking about like
that yeah that was that that that
there's no such thing that like that
Islam is just like any other religion
and like that they're ignoring
like that like the majority of Muslims
like the live outside of the US the
United States or the UK or whatever that
really are like living in horrible
conditions don't look at me I'm really
like fantastically compared to other
people even in Egypt
I know bothers me I do whatever I want
but some people can't and when you start
saying things like that's like races to
just say that we should like keep an eye
on
some issues that are very important and
you should like you're liberal that's
the problem - you should you know you
should actually leave everything and
just focus on that there are people
getting murdered for being gay or saying
the wrong thing or for listening to
wrong kind of music or you should do
that you should champion that cause not
just for people living outside areas
just live inside us and and the work
travel because you know the internet and
all that and don't even get me started
on this nonsense about like feminism
Islam yeah we you know what here's what
we do for real I'm gonna do an hour with
you because this is just the beginning
and I truly am a fan of yours so we're
gonna do a full hour together so I'm
sorry we had to cut it short and you
know what I was I think I told you this
but I was in Egypt back in 1997 it feels
like a lifetime ago and I would love to
go back at some point so maybe we can
work that - yep just call me Apple we
like your tour guide I'm gonna show you
like the pyramids all the cliches and
other stuff - all right I am on with
cushaw from India who shall you are
number one you are first on the big
Rueben report fan show how's it going in
India today know us today namaste so I'm
really happy that you have me over it
goes good it's really hot right now
actually yeah that's what's really hot
for you guys oh we dealing Celsius not
Fahrenheit so it's actually recognized
35 degrees Celsius with the humidity of
77 percent that's pretty hot
oh man are you are you an air
conditioning right now you just have a
serious fans air conditioning yeah very
nice
all right well I'm super excited to talk
to you now I don't know we got a lot of
responses I don't know that all 1.2
billion with the be people in India
responded but we did get a ton of
responses from India about a hundred
people so so you're the you're the lucky
one out of a hundred so there was a lot
of things that you sent me that I
thought were really really interesting
so first off and a few people in India
talked about this you mentioned just the
general state of freedom of expression
in India right now so can you tell me a
little bit about
concerns about the state of freedom of
expression so here's the thing I don't
want to paint a very you know dangerous
scenario or something on that sort but
you know as a skeptic I almost kept it
myself so I mean in India we have some
weird laws so I'll give you an example
of a couple of situations so it all
starts with a particular constitutional
article called 295 a mm-hmm so basically
that article restricts any criticism of
religion so I'm not gonna give the whole
text of the article to you because that
would just take away a lot of time but
sure the article says that you cannot
hurt the sentiments of religious people
and here's the funny part so it's
basically a blasphemy law and India is a
80 percent Hindu country and Hinduism
does not even have a concept of
blasphemy right so I mean it's hilarious
actually but the history of the law is
that in 1926 I think it was in 1926 we
had this publisher who published a book
called Angela Rasul so it's a word in
Hindi so the regular assume means
Prophet Muhammad the Casanova or the
Playboy so it basically spoke about the
the marriages and the sex life of
Prophet Muhammad now obviously Muslims
did not like it at that time and there
was a lot of rioting this is in 1926 so
eventually the publisher was murdered
and the British shows because they
didn't want to deal with it they just
came up with this blasphemy law and
we're just stuck with it now till 2016
right so wait hold on so if Hindu if
Hinduism has no blasphemy so it's really
only being used one way it really sort
of has nothing to do with Hinduism right
yeah it's not but the tragedy is that
even Hindus have started using this law
that's the tragedy you see see I I might
be a skeptic but I don't consider myself
to be outside the Hindu pantheon because
you know we don't have that Abrahamic
problem there you know 80s are
considered outside the Abrahamic
pantheon Hinduism had a very healthy
tradition of atheism built in in itself
yeah it hurts me even more because I
consider myself to be a Hindu and we
have this law and nobody talks about it
I mean there have been rationalist who
had to
leave Indy I'll give you an example
there was a rationalist called Sanel i
don't know his second name but i know
his name so now so he basically went
around in 2012 when he was talking about
how certain miracles claimed by
Christians were not real
so they used this law and they went down
on him and he had to leave India he
stays in Finland now and that's really
sad recently there was a chameleon Kiku
Sharda he makes fun of a Sikh guru so
the followers of that guru they went
after him again he had to apologize and
I can give you examples of various
religions obviously I mean the highest
amount of offense is caused by a
particular religion which nobody talks
about right I got I got a lot of emails
about that I think everyone knows which
one you're talking about so one of the
things that you wrote that I thought was
really interesting you said you wanted
to make the distinction between
tolerance and mutual respect and I
really thought that was fascinating
because here in America at least we talk
about tolerance all the time we have to
tolerate everybody but in a way that's
not a very lofty thing mutual respect is
so can you explain that so basically
it's not something that I've come up
with it's a concept that was discussed
and you know basically it's a concept
introduced by Indian American author
called Rajiv Malhotra he wrote a book
called being different in 2011 so what
he basically talks about is every time
we have an interfaith dialogue right so
you have these interfaith dialogues
where everybody around the table says oh
we tolerate all religions you know Rajee
spoke about it in a very beautiful way
so duh you know he went around asking
people so do you tolerate your spouse in
your house do you tolerate someone when
you're having dinner with them right so
I have just basically taken this concept
being a skeptic now I'm taking it to the
next level and I'm saying okay Here I am
I'm a skeptic I may not agree with some
views of Hinduism I may not agree with a
lot of views of Islam or Christianity
but their mutual respect comes in is I
don't need to tolerate you I need to
respect you and you need to give me that
respect back in return that's when you
have a dialogue tolerances you're saying
you suck but it's okay I'll let you be
right but I won't kill
you pretty much that's that's tolerate
and this is again it stems from this
exclusivist nature of Abrahamic
religions see Hindus don't have this
problem and I'm being very honest yeah I
mean I've never faced a Hindu saying you
know I'm never come across a Hindu who
says I'll tolerate you
you know Hindus would be like okay you
don't believe in God you do your own
thing I'll do my own thing right but you
know it's not like one god one book one
religion it's not that so does that make
the state of atheists in India much
stronger actually because I did get
above I would say probably half of the
people that emailed us from India said
they were atheists and didn't make it
sound like they were hiding per se
obviously you're doing this right now so
if Hinduism which is 80% of the religion
in India is sort of tolerant of atheism
that's that's pretty fantastic right
yeah you know see I like to classify
Indian atheism in three parts so there
are the Hindu atheist or the Hindu
thermic skeptics I call myself a dharmic
skeptic so we we are not sure about some
claims of Hinduism so I would say I am
skeptical to reincarnation
I'm skeptical to a few claims that the
gurus make but there are a lot of things
in Hinduism that are beautiful I mean I
personally like the theory of karma as a
action and reaction
I think karma could be taken as an
action and reaction mm-hmm but then
there are there's this new atheism in
India I call them the Marxist atheists
so basically you have to understand Indy
the political scenario in India and
especially the media you have the social
sciences and the humanities departments
they keep churning out these Marxist
atheists so when you got a lot of emails
I won't be surprised that you must have
gotten a lot of emails of those Marxist
atheists who paint a very different
picture about Hinduism to you mm-hmm
and then I have the third category which
is the wannabe at ease
so that person has not read anything so
they just probably saw a video of
Richard Dawkins on YouTube so and they
must have gone ok I like this right now
right it's like that so I have three
categorizations of atheism in India they
belong the dynamic skeptic yeah well
listen
we I feel like we just started and
you're my first person out of 20 but our
time is up already
but I really I appreciate your support I
appreciate you coming on and sharing
your thoughts and I have got to make it
out to India so when I do I'm gonna look
you up yeah
when you come to Mumbai dinners on me
done and done
alright I am here with Hannah in Texas
in the good old US of A Hannah how are
you I am amazing how are you I'm doing
well
it's Texas it feels like Texas is like a
whole other country in a way what's
going on in Texas well honestly I think
that we are better than North Carolina
right now that's pretty good that's
pretty good yeah I mean like we got we
get a lot of a bad rap here but at the
same time when you actually live here it
really depends on where you live why
Texas is bigger than like France or
something right so I live close to
Dallas not super close but about an hour
away from that and the closer you are to
these major cities the better it is but
whenever you start getting out to the
rural areas it gets kind of dickish but
they're good people like it's always
like well-intentioned good old boys sort
of thing going on all right all right
I'll go with that well your submission
was really great because you gave me a
you gave me a lot to work with me so
first off you are trans big deal but you
are trans um yes and I put a little
asterisk on that um I am somebody who's
very anti labels and there's a reason
for this I'm not again the special
snowflake stuff later but I don't know
what I'm agreeing to whenever I say yes
I'm trans right I mean like how far does
that go that's always kind of the big
question whenever you're saying are you
a trans man trans woman transsexual
transgender across where are the lines
you know what I mean - if I say yes I am
that by in a colloquial general
understanding at the very basic level
yes I think that's really interesting
and it's actually kind of freeing
because you
as the person that identifies however
you want to identify you're making the
point of saying well sometimes these
labels are a little confusing or don't
quite get it right or all that well
meanwhile society is just obsessed with
these labels right mm-hmm
yeah it's I have been doing this for
close to nine years now the thing with
the the Internet is that you don't
really know who is typing what so for
the for the most part a lot of like the
trans stuff that comes out and people
doing that it's probably people just
trying on a persona or trying on an
identity or something like that usually
teenagers and I think that we kind of
take them a little bit more seriously
than we should on a national like
hysteria type level um but I don't
necessarily see that there's much wrong
with it but just let it be what it is
instead of making a big deal out of it
if it's online like in person stuff like
real tangible happenings that gets a
little bit more attention or should like
people online typing or posting or
whatnot variously that could be anybody
are you telling me are you telling me
that tumblr is not real life is that
what you're telling me I know it'll blow
your mind wow you know you can be
anything on the internet like it's that
helicopter that ones really yeah all
right so let's let's back up a little
bit so for someone that's watching this
right now wherever they are in the world
that has never heard from a trans person
or the only trans person that they know
of is Caitlyn Jenner can you just tell
me a little bit about growing up when
did you realize you were trans etc this
is always very difficult because
everybody's gonna have like a similar
overarching narrative but it's gonna
have its different details
I knew something was off as a child
which is one of those common narratives
but um I grew up
and Baptist and being raised that way
it's very kind of closed off everybody
that wasn't Southern Baptist was
influenced by the devil but we moved
around a lot and all that sort of thing
and just I don't know how to qualify
myself like we are kind of the only
people it seems nowadays where you have
to explain yourself rationalize to me
why I should accept that you are who you
say you are right you guys are the ones
at the moment but you know what that
won't last forever for whatever so it's
one of those deals where it's like I
wish I could give a definitive answer
like this is exactly how I know I can
point to these scientific studies this
is exactly what happened
I can't we don't we're not there yet hey
when I can point to is that trans people
have existed throughout history and
multiple cultures this is not a new
thing it is only new to the American
West
and what I mean by that is the modern
American West native tribes different
allowances for different genders and
gender roles sure so it's only new to
you know the North American West and I
think that kind of goes back to like
Puritan European influence and whatnot
kind of scrounging all deviancy from the
possibility of human experience and I'm
sure that there were people and I you
know white European Colonials or
whatever that were also trans but could
not say anything risk of being hung or
killed or whatever yeah so yeah I'm
curious how much of your sort of just
mental energy and an ability to be a
functioning person is about just having
to explain yourself because that's that
seems more exhausting in a way than then
dealing with something personal it is
exhausting and it was exhausting I think
a lot of trans people go through very
similar phases in their transition when
I first started I was at helper I was
going to be there for my
you know transistors who were just
starting also I spent a lot of nights
sleepless trying to keep people from
killing themselves but also trying to
educate and explain and all this sort of
thing and as time went on and I got more
passing privilege as we call it that I
didn't have as many people stopping me
and asking me and I kind of developed
sort of a passive routine of like this
is how I'm just gonna interact with
people and just be super kind super
sweet and all that sort of thing and
there is that pressure that you always
have to be on your a-game transwoman
around the normal people or whatever
right and there's there's two camps on
this there's the the radical queers who
are like we should not be trying to fit
in we are unique in our own way and it's
beautiful and all this sort of thing and
then there's the people who are like
well no I don't I kind of just want to
fit in you know and it's difficult
trying to navigate this because it's
very politicized if you choose one side
or the other or you try to not pick a
side nobody's gonna like you and you end
up in your room that is that one is that
one of the hardest things about sort of
being not only being a minority in this
regard but like as I said trans issues
seem to be the minority of the moment as
you referenced before this issue with
the bathrooms in North Carolina
everything trans is you know makes
Drudge and it makes all the news so do
you feel that you're under a microscope
even in just your private life with
everything that you do he yes and here's
here's the thing I have been using the
women's restroom for eight years without
any issue now I'm scared because I mean
that's interesting how people are
looking now people are scrutinizing and
whenever governor's or mayor's or
whoever it was in North Carolina says
women should spray people you know they
if they're scared in the bathroom and
you're a year ago a girl with them and
I'm gonna get in trouble for saying this
a genetic girl with a vagina
actually got pulled out of a restroom by
men because did you say a genetic aisle
with a vagina so a female reg a
cisgender female right well enough got
it right so that's a specific issue and
it always makes me wonder whenever like
things like this happen like what else
is going on like what what are the real
issues that are going on right now
whenever they put this panic out here
like we've been around all this time
yeah but just for now for some reason
right now now we have to talk about this
like now we need to have this national
discussion what's the real issue like
what's what's happening I'm well you
know what the news cycle is pretty quick
so I think this one hopefully were
shifted out of this one yeah
it's the processing area that um just
saying this is low in my mind yeah
that's more of a specific issue and this
like the trans experience is hugely
diverse as diverse as the queer
experience and again I'm like who do you
define as trans because if you go with
the tumblr versions or whatnot if you
cross dress on Halloween for Rocky
Horror Picture Show you qualify as trans
now congratulations and you can't really
say well no you don't qualify if you're
in that community because suddenly
you're removing somebody's identity and
you're gonna get in trouble for that and
all that sort of things so I'm just
gonna wing I need to accept the concept
of qualia I don't know if you're
familiar with that but no yeah I quality
as a term I'm kind of like I think so
much that I am an armchair philosopher
but qualia was a word that was coined
that was to describe the specific
experience that we each have so whenever
you look at like a blue wall you will
have a certain range of emotions and
feelings and all that and I will have a
a supposedly different one and that is
quality so we can relate that we're
looking at a blue wall but whatever is
invoked inside us is going to be
different so that's kind of like the
trans experience and that's the best I
can do
when it comes to rationalizing you know
I was like I just know what I feel and
I'm sorry that you can't relate and
again with the bathroom issue oh my gosh
well listen I appreciate oh well I mean
like I appreciate people trying to
relate to the trans issues and like and
whenever they think of the bathroom
thing they're like why would I go to the
bathroom or why do I think people would
go to the bathroom first thing comes to
mind well sexual assault or something
right and I'm like mold you should not
get in a dress and going to the bathroom
then like you're messed up see there is
one other thing that I wanted to talk
about that you mentioned in your
submission that I thought was really
interesting you brought up a phrase that
I hadn't heard before called constructed
illusion and you related this to having
a male and female voice and when you may
use each one can you tell me about that
so this is what people will call
performing gender so I have developed
this voice with years of training it's
still my voice it's just exercised right
my arms aren't exercised but so I have a
wider range so with this voice I get
treated different whenever I interact
with people because I'm not threatening
with this voice but if you're ready for
this if I drop my voice I suddenly
become a threat right so I I can switch
between these two but that was the voice
that's affected by student testosterone
and anybody who heard that I am
immediately a different person there's
no going back
right the illusion is broken but how do
they know that's just not another one of
my develop voices and this is kind of
why I call it constructed illusion
because it's it's related to magic
tricks performance magic you can you do
misdirection
all that sort of thing and it is a
performance in a sense but in another
since it is me it's really hard to
really unpack that and short amount of
time but it's intersubjectivity with my
voice it was for me at first but
eventually I can I start feeling trapped
by it because even though I've exercised
this voice I'm still not capable of a
full range of emotional expression using
it that makes sense right but I assume
that there's a revolution with that
right like you'll you'll get there so to
speak eventually but it takes a lot a
lot a lot of practice so this this goes
back in like passing privilege and all
that sort of thing so yeah it was really
nice talking to you and I promise
amazing [ __ ] you so ecstatic alright I'm
on with Jason in Brussels Jason how's it
going fantastic
yeah well I'm excited to talk to you so
you are in Brussels but originally from
Cyprus so we're gonna get as we're gonna
get to Cyprus in a minute because nobody
talks about Cyprus but it's a really
interesting tiny little country that
very few people know about but you're in
Brussels now obviously the last few
months in Belgium but especially in
Brussels have been very tough so can you
just start with that
well yeah I have to say it hasn't
affected people on a on a conscious
level I mean you see people going about
their daily routine but it's definitely
had a very malicious sort of
subconscious under terms particularly
since the Paris attacks we've had
martial law on and off and it's very
concerning when you see four armed
soldiers outside McDonald's and an
armored car outside your workplace yeah
so yeah it's it's it's it's been very
strange and the attacks actually
happened at a metro station that I used
quite frequently so when you see these
changes you see more soldiers out there
you see more security and all that kind
of stuff how does that just change your
general psyche like that you're walking
to work and you're seeing this stuff it
changes just sort of the day-to-day
right well know you've become accustomed
to it actually but I mean it's it's very
disturbing to see the military deployed
in in the West
capital I mean it's like the problems
truly have become global yeah so there
were a lot of reports after the attacks
in Brussels
that in parts of the community that one
of the attackers was from and I guess
they found him a couple weeks later that
the community there was knowingly hiding
him we're people talking about that in
Belgium it's sort of trickled its way
into Western media but not really and
then it was kind of hard to tell what
was actually true well I don't think
this is just a problem that's isolated
to Belgium I think in general we don't
see members of the local community where
many of these suspects are from telling
them in or making a concerted and up
effort with the authorities and it is
something that we have to try and deal
with through better integration policies
yeah so how is the integration going I
guess I guess to that point it's
probably not going that great
no no it's terrible I mean you have
different communities that live parallel
lives who which I mean they they exist
occasionally in the physical space
because I mean you over the physical
spaces overlap slightly but they they
just live in a different reality right
so how much of that where do you place
all the blame on that because this is
one of the things that a lot of people
emailed us about was was this idea
especially people in Europe were saying
that a lot of the Muslim communities
aren't integrating properly and they
some people were sort of blaming their
own government some people were blaming
the the Muslim communities it's my guess
is that the truth is somewhere in
between what do you think well I like to
go from more abstractly and say that the
problem has been to because of our
social justice approach or rather
aggressive approach yeah yeah we're
giving we've been giving rights to
communities rather than to individuals
and it's very arbitrary to define a
community in a certain way and and you
know because the premise of our
individualist kind of rule of law has
been the rights should be given to to
individuals and not to
you know what social justice people
however social justice people decide to
classify people oh yeah so how much have
those ideas clearly you're speaking my
language it's about the individual not
the group let's get away from the
suppression olympics thing all of that
stuff which we've talked about so much
here how much of that ideology is has
taken hold in Belgium well I'm more
qualified to talk about specifically
about how this is manifested in the UK
because I've been doing study on that so
you've been studying this in the UK
about the school system right the school
system yeah because in the in the
British school system what you have is
you have a third of schools which are
regarded as which are faith schools they
receive public money because they
haven't designated a religious character
and what we see here is that I believe
that the child's rights being infringed
upon
because basically because the child is
classified as as as belonging to a
particular community they get labeled by
very arbitrary criteria and and attend
faith schools just to fulfill the aims
of social justice and I think that this
is this is a very large structural
problem it's a bizarrely backwards thing
that we do in the West I mean we do this
in America with several religions where
the government's funds sort of
faith-based schools even though we're a
totally secular society well yes and and
you know shockingly in the UK the faith
schools have have an exemption from from
even the Equality Act
I mean it's written in the law that they
have an exemption from treating people
equally in employment and an admission
and the problem is although the schools
are obliged to teach the National
Curriculum they teach it through a
religion
length so you might learn about many
secular subjects but then and about
other religions and secularism and how
to behave in a civic society but if you
also learned that the penalty for
apostasy is dead and that the law and
that the law of God in the Sharia is
above the law of the state then you're
less likely to want to integrate and be
part of the cohesive society yeah I mean
to me that's that gets to the heart of
the social justice stuff because it
seeps into the education system then you
have a government that is subsidizing
basically religious teaching suicide
yeah all right so let's move away from
that for a little cuz I do want to talk
about Cyprus with you so nobody knows
about Cyprus it is a tiny little island
country you're from there just tell me a
little bit about your history you don't
have to give me the whole history of
Cyprus but tell me a little history that
that's most significant now yeah yeah
well in 1974 the Turkish army occupied
half of Cyprus and the island has been
divided since then the Turkish state
installed a kind of vague Republic
that's only recognized by Turkey and
Pakistan and they've been ongoing
attempts to resolve the situation over
the decades but I feel that I'm not very
optimistic about the two sides coming to
a settlement because of the physical
power that Turkey is exerting I think
whether Turkey withdraws a lot is mainly
a subject of the trajectory of Turkish
foreign policy and whether it's in
Turkey's interest to leave yeah and my
hope is that because Turkish foreign
policy has become increasingly is Lanna
fide and that it's shifting away from
the foreign policy of the West that the
West might slowly and Isis there's a
growing relationship between Cyprus and
Israel and my hope is that the west
eventually aligns its foreign policy
closer to secularists entities
throughout the region I like the Kurds
for example also yeah
and my hope is that that will will lead
to a better will will give Cyprus
leverage in negotiations because it will
have the more backing from the west
let's see yeah well I promise you that I
will talk about it more because you know
we've talked about the Kurds here but as
you said Cyprus is a sovereign nation a
United Nations member country and it's
in full occupation since 1974 so there's
a lot listen there's a lot more that we
could talk about unfortunately we got to
move on I got a long day of interviews
but it's been a pleasure talking to you
alright I'm on with Jill up in Canada
Jill how are you I'm good thanks well
it's good to have you here now first off
before we get into any of the issues you
emailed me about is it true that Canada
is gonna build a wall to keep Americans
out regardless of who wins our
presidential election I've heard rumors
yes okay rumors all right we're gonna
get that on the Internet okay so you
sent me some really interesting stuff
that just sort of touched on some of the
things that we talked about on the show
but then you really went in another
direction with it which is why I wanted
to have you on so one of the things you
mentioned is that sort of the mental
health anti-stigma campaigns that we see
these days are actually part of the
regressive left ideology now I gave a
lot of buzzwords there so can you unpack
that for me a little bit I think so not
very many people agree with me on that
well let's see let's see well it's the
same sort of victim mentality except
pretty much anyone can be a part of it
it seems almost like a club to be
mentally ill these days and a lot of
times it ignores the real issues like
right now in Canada we have a huge
crisis with the First Nations
communities like lots of youth are
committing suicide but of course the
anti-stigma campaigns want to hijack
this and make it about illness but if
you actually talk to these youth they
say well we have no hope because there
is no hope here we have no jobs we have
no library things like that so I think
just the campaign's tend to really
fairway for
issues and tend to put people again in
the victim role yeah so you're sort of
talking about two things there so on one
hand there's the feeling if the economy
is not good or their family life isn't
good or whatever else it is sort of a
reality in their life versus these
campaigns that in a weird way because of
this oppression Olympics that we've
talked about kind of make it cool to say
well this is wrong with me or this is
wrong with me or I have this or this or
that correct yeah there seems to be a
bit of a hierarchy like it's more cool
to be like bipolar than to be depressed
and and they seem to be saying accept me
because I'm not like you whereas we all
know like the way towards acceptance is
to be well we're all human we're all the
same but they're really going for no
because I'm different and it's not my
fault yeah so sort of for people who
don't have an illness what does that
mean if they're struggling that they
shouldn't be accepted so right that's
really kind of fascinating so someone
who doesn't have any any known condition
so to speak in a weird way then then it
feels worse for them because they're
supposed to feel okay right yeah yeah
and there's a lot of research showing
that the more we sort of give people
these information about these illnesses
the more we create them in people
because it's it's very much cultural and
but they just have to get a brain scan
and people pay attention because they
think that science yeah do you guys have
all the crazy commercials that we have
in the states you know you turn on the
TV especially any of the cable news
shows and all the commercials are for
one depression medicine or another and
you know there's a cartoon cloud
following somebody and take this
medication with this medication and it
makes everybody think that they're
depressed or somehow defective yeah I
don't watch TV but I'm sure we do have
those you're you're a wise woman so a
lot of this though from what you wrote
to me is very personal for you because
you're a recovering addict yourself
right hmm yeah so can you tell me a
little bit about that
there you know what you were doing how
you got out etc
I don't have to give me every bit of
personal stuff but yeah I was a heroin I
guess I still am a heroin addict I don't
know how much to say about that yeah and
and you are you you're in full recovery
or I guess it's a lifelong struggle I
suppose right yeah almost two years Wow
so the other thing that you wanted to
talk about which of course is related to
all this is the war on drugs and you
know this is something we talk about a
lot in America I'm not that familiar
with the with the drug situation in
Canada in general can you tell me a bit
I don't follow politics as much as I
should I get I get too depressed but I
have read a lot of Bruce Alexander's
work and Vancouver which is where I'm
from originally has the worst addiction
problem in the world
pretty much so he talks a lot about how
globalization has affected that and the
war on drugs pretty much focuses on the
drugs themselves as being evil and it's
really not about the drugs
Bruce Alexander's work in the 70s he
pretty much disproved all other notions
of addiction but people have still held
on to it mm-hmm
basically it was called rat Park he gave
some rats morphine water and of course
they used it up which is pretty much
identical almost to heroin right but
then he puts another group of rats in
like a bigger container where they could
socialize and they could play and they
had lots of room and those rats wouldn't
drink the Marking water hmm even when
they had already forced them into
physical dependency so unlike to me is
evidence against this whole crazy notion
that we should be fighting drugs
Canada isn't probably in the same state
as America but we are certainly getting
there yeah but you guys do have some
places Vancouver for example where at
least marijuana is legal right
um it's not legal I don't think we do
have the safe injection sites but our
Conservative government's our previous
Conservative government tried really
hard to get rid of that Oh mommy hmm
that's interesting well listen it's it's
fascinating to me because you took sort
of a theme related to you know political
correctness and the suppression stuff
and all that and applied it to something
that we haven't talked about that much
so I really appreciate your thoughts on